[Music]
today we're going to
walk you through our restoration of
a pair of ugg boots
the process starts by checking the boots
in
and then we go to the cleaning process
where danny will be doing what we call
pre-spotting he's using a steam gun
to try and clean the soles the best
possible
so the steaming of the soles is is
mostly to get the grit and little
pebbles and
and grime off of the soles it's really
effective in
knocking that off that the washing
process or the wet cleaning process
alone will not do when
danny is doing the brushing this is with
a
soft nylon bristle brush and
our formula of soap surfactant
with oil and a solvent it will help
break down that hard watermark
and the products that we use will not
disturb the color
after danny finishes the pre-spotting we
will go right
to the machine where we have formulas
set up
for this type of cleaning
okay and they go
these ugg boots are probably generally
washed at around
75 or 80 degree temperature
you have to have a little bit of warmth
in there for the surfactants the the
soaps and the oils to work properly
20 minutes later we're ready to take
them out
when we take the boots out of the
machine
there is a bit of a hopping back
shrinking back process that happens in
this wet cleaning
uggs have a tendency to stretch out when
you're wearing them and so
we are trying to stretch them back out a
little bit but more
shape them and then he's taking little
terry cloth rags that we have and
putting them in the toe
so that the toe will keep a nice round
shape when they dry when danny is
finished shaping the boot he'll put them
on the drying rack
and they'll usually stay on the drying
rack for
24 hours to 36 hours
after we get the boots off the drying
rack and they're totally dry
missy will take them and use a 3m
pad they make several different uh
grades of these pads and this one is a
light to medium coarseness pad and
it's perfect for what we call shaving or
brushing
the sheepskin to bring up the nap
when the suede wears it will literally
wear the nap
off of the skin and so one of the things
that we want to do
is brush that nap back up and make it so
that you don't see
where it was worn now we're going to
spray them up
to the spray booth missy
is spraying the boot with what we call a
neutral
suede oil for uh
the the suede there are water repellent
properties to the oil and
at that point we added a little dye
to the oil to help camouflage
that very slight trace of
the hard water mark that we were trying
to eliminate
after the oiling and the drying period
generally an hour or so we will come
back
and brush up the nap and in doing this
we're inspecting
to make sure that the color is even and
we've rejuvenated the
the suede the nap the velvety look
sometimes in the in the wet cleaning
process
the fur will pick up little teeny bits
of the suede
and so she will brush that fur to remove
any of that suede lint that might have
gotten on the boots in the wet cleaning
process
so the final step is the water repellent
the water repellent that we use on the
uggs is designed to help protect them
from moisture and wet type
stains it won't make the boot waterproof
that's pretty much impossible but it
will go a long way to making it repel
spots and stains and then they will be
inspected and if they go through the
final inspection process
they're ready to be packaged and shipped
off
to their owner
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you